-Our next guest is
an Emmy-winning journalist
and MSNBC's chief
legal correspondent.
He hosts "The Beat" weekdays
at 6:00 p.m. on MSNBC.
Please welcome back to the sho
Ari Melber.
♪♪♪♪
Hello!
-Hey.
-Welcome.
Ari, it's so lovely to have you.
-Great to see you.
-You were here in December
the last time you were here.
You had just done I believ
five hours of coverage
because the IG report,
the inspector's general report
had just come out.
Do you even remember
what that was about?
-I feel like that was a review
of the Russia probe?
I feel like
there were lot of reports.
-There were a lot of reports
And that both seems very distant
in the past,
and yet it also -- you know,
certainly Trump's legal problems
remain in the present,
and you were booked
before we knew what was going to
happen today with Rudy Giuliani.
You know, federal agents
going into his apartment.
This is a big deal.
-It's a huge deal.
It is the second time
that a lawyer for Donald Trump
has seen his own place raided.
Last time, everyone remembers,
it was Michael Cohen.
He was raided. He was indicted
He ultimately went to jail
So it's bad news
for Rudy Giuliani.
And we'll find out if it's
bad news for Donald Trump.
-There has to be a very --
The threshold, I would imagine
is higher when you're actually
talking about
going into a lawyer's home
to seize material.
-Yes.
-Is that safe to say?
-Very safe to say.
So, "The New York Times" reports
that there was enough evidence
that prosecutors wanted to d
this last year.
Then they wanted to do it agai
while Rudy was leading
his increasingly bizarre
and baroque challenge
to the election
on Donald Trump's behalf.
Both times Trump appointee
in Washington stopped this move.
So it's with
a new administration,
and the reason they were abl
to stop it is
that you actually have to
get higher clearance
to go into a lawyer's home
or a lawyer's office
because, yes, they do have
confidential information.
-Now, would it have been maybe
better for Rudy
if this had happened
when Trump was still president
so that Trump
could've pardoned him,
which is no longer
a possibility?
-This is the most Trumpian
of questions, right?
If you're surrounded by people
who are indicted criminals
and then you just
schedule your pardons
the way other people schedul
showing up
to your friends' birthdays
you want to get your crime don
really early
in the administration,
if you're going to do it all
legally.
And so people like Steve Banno
and others, obviously,
did get their pardons --
Roger Stone.
If Rudy Giuliani runs into
future legal problems --
I'm not saying he will or not,
but it's bad.
-I will. I think he will.
[ Laughter ]
-But it's bad to be raided
like this
because an independent judge
has signed off on the idea
that there's evidence of crime
in your home,
so that's a bad thing.
And if he runs into future
problems, Trump can't help him
-President Biden
speaking tonight.
We don't know --
We're on after he speaks,
but we don't know
what he's gonna say yet.
How do you feel his agenda
has been executed
so far as we hit 100 days?
-One thing that almost everyon
agreed about Joe Biden
in Washington and in the country
over the last 30 years
is that he was nice and boring
And now, he's had this excitin
start to the presidency,
and the type of money
he's spending makes him look
more like someone who just
signed his first record deal
than the moderate,
boring president
that many thought he would be.
-And yet he also might be
ticking some boring boxes
in that the press doesn't have
to sort of breathlessly report
on things he says
and does every day.
-And I think
it's a deliberate strategy
We'll see what happens
in the years to come.
I got to go to the White House
earlier this week,
reporting on the speech,
as you mentioned.
And the whole mood and vib
is, "It's different now.
We can all be adults
and calm down."
And there seems to be
a political benefit for that
We've heard so much about
how polarized everything is.
Joe Biden's first bill
had more Republican suppor
than what most people expected
for a big "liberal"
spending bill.
And I think it's partly people
welcome a change of pace.
-I want to ask
about your reaction
to the Chauvin guilty verdict.
Obviously, there was
video evidence that,
to a lot of people's eyes,
seem very clear
that a crime had been committed.
But were you surprised wit
the guilty verdict insofar
as we so rarely see it
in cases of police violence?
-Seeing a U.S. police office
convicted of murder
is a complete and total rarity
The United States has one of the
highest rates of police killings
in the world and then they'r
also racially discriminatory
But just to put a point on it,
from 2006 to 2015,
with thousands of killings
there were zero murder
convictions
of police officers
for on-duty killings.
So it even happening is rare
Whether this means
it may happen more often
and there may be
a deterrent or not,
I just think
it's too early to tell.
-We've often talked about
your love of hip-hop
when you've joined us, and you
posted this photo recently
I would say, if I didn't kno
this was you,
I wouldn't be able
to guess it was you,
but I would know
that was 50 Cent.
-I think 50 Cent is the more
identifiable and famous person
in a mask in the photo.
-Yes. How is he doing?
-50's great.
-Yeah?
-I mean, 50 is
a busy rapper and entrepreneur
and he's producing television.
And he's actually much warme
and more cuddly
than the kind of bullying
persona he has on the Internet
And we're living in
a time of still debates
over facts and science,
and I do think --
I didn't know
you had that photo handy -
but I do think, you know,
50 said,
"I hate a liar more
than I hate a thief.
A thief is after my salary
A liar is after my reality."
-You know what?
I would let you talk again
but how are you going to say
something better than that
[ Laughter ]
"The Beat" airs weekdays
at 6:00 p.m. on MSNBC.